hey guys if it's your first time here on
my channel I'm Daniel and welcome to
deal and model lifestyle now what are
the best ways to look a little bit
better in wearing a shirt is to wear
your color upright and straight why
because it gives the impression of a
good quality shirt and you look better
in it but how do you keep your color or
strength because as you probably already
know most shirts don't do this naturally
well that's what I'm going to talk about
in this video
let's get mistakes make all right so how
do you keep your shirt color straight up
to frame your face a little bit better
and not look down look well oh well
[Music]
first you have to get the right color
stop these are on 12 basic different
color styles now it's important to know
that the size and the white of the color
spread influences how it will sit on you
so if you want to wear a shirt with an
open color then the color needs to be
strong so try to get a spread collar
white collar because it is a little bit
shorter in size and lighter so it will
stand up a little bit better than the
other type of colors like the
button-down or point colors and then
another thing to look at is the height
here at the back of the collar so the
higher the collar is here at the back
the better it will stand firm especially
if it hasn't makes your button
but you can also do is reinforce the
placket the placket gives structure and
strengthens the color so if you
reinforce the placket it will
automatically reinforce the front of the
shirt and keep your collar up now a
French placket doesn't have a common
front placket so if you don't wear a tie
if your collar is open chances are it's
gonna collapse now what you want is a
standard placket it has a visible seam
next to the buttons it's folded and sewn
down the front as a separate piece now
this is what you want because it adds
stability to the front of the shirt and
it keeps your collar up use spray starch
on your collar the next plan if you use
a normal iron.most if miss to the
placket and collar but I gotta warn you
if you have sensitive skin then maybe
it's not a good idea if you use it
because it can irritate your skin a
little bit now of course you can also
get magnetic clips and double-sided tape
which is actually what I'm wearing right
now it works well for the flesh but not
so well for the placket and I'm just a
bonus that when you do go out and you
buy a shirt get one with a color stay
all it is is a metal or plastic strip
that keeps your color in place now if
you want to improve your style and check
out this playlist and it will help you
out I'll see you there just guys